if you could tag team with any
professional wrestler who would it be
that question yeah they could have gone
South could have been really pleasant
too
any current professional wrestler any
any any in the in in the top in the in
the world of of any time period Well I'm
gonna go at Cody Rhodes my boy you
you've already worked with Cody Rhodes I
I tag teamed against against Cody Rhodes
against him that's right yeah do you
want to do it again do you want to do
something like that again I do want to
do it again I need to make sure that I
will be
you asked earlier if I would be upset
devastated or what have you if
if there wasn't a season three of heels
uh the thing that would really
that the thing that I would really
really really have a problem with is if
we didn't get a season three and I
didn't do everything that I could
promoting season two and I think that
everything that I can do will involve me
being back on
television doing some wrestling in some
way shape or form